what's the latest as we understand has
happened at this school
yeah horrific details emerging this
afternoon from the small town of uvalde
in texas it's a town around 90 miles
southwest
of the city of san antonio and we're
told that a gunman entered an elementary
school so these are primary school age
children we're talking about
around noon today the governor of texas
greg abbott has been giving a press
conference in the last 20 minutes he
says that 14 children have very sadly
been killed being shot dead in that
incident along with one teacher
it was believed at one point that the
gunman had been taken into custody but
the governor greg abbott said that
that's not correct he says that the
gunman was shot by an attending officer
you can see here
a caravan of emergency service vehicles
responding to the scene of this shooting
at the robb elementary school in uvalde
it's not far from the texas mexico the
u.s mexico border
down in texas so
as you'd expect there were border patrol
on the scene there
sheriff's teams and other emergency
service responders
the governor of texas said he believes
that shooter abandoned his vehicle and
entered that school with a handgun he
said he may also have had a rifle uh he
he said he believed as i mentioned
before that that shooter was killed by
an attending officer
if this death toll is correct of 14
children and one teacher killed as it
seems to be it means this is the
deadliest deadliest mass school shooting
in america since the sandy hook massacre
in 2012 when 26 people were killed
including
20 very young children
at that school in the wake of that sandy
hook shooting in 2012 there were calls
for major reform on gun gun laws in
america that hasn't happened and we've
seen many many shootings in the
intervening period
the death toll here and the fact that it
was primary school-aged children
who were targeted makes this incident
particularly horrific it also comes just
a week after a shooting in buffalo in
upstate new york a racially motivated
shooting where 10 people
were killed so horrific details still
emerging from the small town of uvalde
in texas at the moment we believe 14
children two adults including one
teacher have been killed there are also
other people being treated in hospitals
in that local area for their injuries
okay martha for now thank you very much
reporting back to you when we get more
detail on this horrific incident thank
you for now